Trascrizione: Abanoub Abdelmassih
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Sono, prima di tutto,
il rappresentante di una generazione
che non è presente in questa sala.
Sono molto -
(Applausi)
e credo [di essere] intervenuto
per il mio interesse,
per la attenzione che ho
per i problemi dell'innovazione,
e per la preoccupazione che ho
tra le cose che ho sentito,
e che hanno dei ritardi,
e di cui mi aspetto
si trovino delle soluzioni
in un paese che ha ritardi enormi.
Io non sono un tecnologo.
Devo la mia fortuna
alla cattiva calligrafia.
Nel 1955, quando mi sono fidanzato -
per quattro mesi che sono stato fidanzato,
poi in fretta mi sono sposato,
ho scritto tutte le lettere a macchina,
perché sono illeggibile.
e dico che la tastiera
mi ha condotto a tutti i passaggi
fino a Ipad, Iphone, eccetera,
compreso uno strumento
molto poco usato: il Kindle.
Io sono un grande lettore,
e porto con me la mia biblioteca,
i miei libri, eccetera.
Di recente ho riletto
"L'uomo senza qualità":
è un libro di Musil che pesa un chilo
e alla mia età sarebbe insopportabile.
Per quello io dico che quando
sento parlare, anche dai giovani:
"Ah, il profumo della carta!"
ricordo loro che la carta di oggi
non è quella di un secolo fa
e che oggi forse viviamo
la rivoluzione di Guthenberg.
Dobbiamo effettivamente correre
verso tutte queste situazioni.
E i ritardi del paese sono ritardi
molto pesanti, molto gravi.
È di oggi l'informazione
che il programma sulla banda larga
è stato ancora rinviato.
Pensiamo che la Corea
ha completato, nel 2012,
la connessione di tutte le case coreane
a una banda larga di 1 Gb per secondo,
che comporta una media di applicazione
di 200 volte quella americana.
Questi sono i temi
che ci fanno competere.
Perché è vero che ci sono
delle buone volontà,
che ci sono delle start-up.
che si parla - anche a iosa,
secondo me - di start-up.
Ieri uno dei fondatori
della Whatsapp
ha venduto la sua quota
per sei miliardi di dollari.
Pertanto, ha incassato sei miliardi
e se ne è liberato.
Ricordiamoci che,
quando parliamo delle start-up,
dobbiamo portare degli elementi
che incidono nella trasformazione,
nella modifica del Paese.
Ora, qui noi non ne abbiamo
perché le start-up arrivano
dove vive un sistema finanziario,
cioè dove noi abbiamo delle banche.
Oh, parliamo di Veneto Sviluppo,
eccetera - non facciamo niente!
Start-up vuol dire iniziative,
due delle quali falliscono
e l'una paga per le altre due.
In questo momento qui,
Singapore vuole ricreare
una Silicon Valley in Singapore.
Investe un miliardo e 700 milioni:
passa da 200 milioni nel 2011
a un miliardo e 700 milioni nel 2014.
Voi capite che quando i paesi
sono capaci di questi sforzi
riescono veramente a portare
elementi di innovazione molto profonda.
E questo pur rispetto la buona volontà,
apprezzabile, encomiabile,
che è stata presentata qui in alcuni casi,
di forza innovativa:
va castigata, se non rinnoviamo il Paese.
Perché è il Paese che ha bisogno
di essere rinnovato.
E su questo io dico che
vorrei vedere molti giovani,
sorprendentemente,
molti giovani non li ho mai visti,
e la mia predica
va fatta soprattutto a loro.
Mi è scappato dire "la predica"
perché alla mia età
sono più propenso a questo
che a dire delle cose creative,
cose che non posso fare.
Questo è l'elemento
su cui bisogna lavorare.
Oggi si è parlato molto di forconi:
Io vorrei che ci fossero
i ventenni, fuori sulle strade,
a chiedere la banda larga.
A chiederne l'applicazione nelle scuole,
chiedere che le scuole siano connesse
con la capacità e la forza innovativa
che ha il Paese, e che
dobbiamo trovare nel Paese.
Senza di questo -
(Applausi)
Senza di questo rischiamo l'implosione.
Il mondo sta cambiando.
Credo che qualcuno di voi saprà già
che uno dei prossimi fabbricanti
di automobili è Google.
Google si sta applicando moltissimo,
e sta spendendo miliardi di dollari,
sullo studio della macchina
senza guidatore.
Qui l'odontoiatra ha parlato
della stampante 3D:
La General Electric sta profondendo
ricchezze e software su questo:
noi abbiamo bisogno di portare qui questo,
sennò le nostre industrie,
e la nostra capacità competitiva,
restano ferme.
Chiudo per dire
che nessuno viene a rubarci la Ferrari,
perché la Ferrari è una struttura
complessa, difficile,
dove c'è bisogno di competenze.
Pertanto abbiamo bisogno di tante Ferrari,
non di tante Electrolux,
che se la viene a prendere la Polonia.
Noi è dalla Germania
che ci dobbiamo guardare.
Dobbiamo vedere questi paesi qui
e crescere verso questa cosa.
(Applausi)
Io vi ringrazio
e mi rallegro di avere visto
una sala piena - mai vista, a Padova;
con tanti giovani - mai visti, a Padova.
Ora adesso mi ritiro, così abbasso
l'età della media, va bene?
Grazie.
(Applausi)